>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> David Plylar: Good
evening everybody.
It's a great pleasure to
see you all here tonight.
My name is David Plylar.
I'm in the music division.
I'm a music specialist there.
And we have a real treat for you
for our preconcert
conversation this evening.
We have composer and
pianist Frederic Rzewski,
who will be performing tonight as
-- his own music, which will be --
we'll have a chance to hear
two piano pieces as well
as the world premiere of a new
piece for violin and piano.
So, we'll talk a bit about that.
And I also have Charlton
Lee, who's the violist
with the Del Sol String
Quartet, and they've been
with us all week doing
really excellent work,
using our instruments, and last
night they performed the String
Quartet from 1955, and we'll
speak a bit about that as well.
So, if you could just join
me in welcoming our guests.
[ Applause ]
>> David Plylar: I'd like to start
with something that's a bit unusual
for me, which is not a
question, but rather a statement,
and this is that I had
the opportunity in 2012
to put together a chamber
concert in South Africa
at the Grahamstown Festival,
which is kind of an obscure part
of South Africa, and we programmed
Coming Together at that performance.
And what was an interesting
thing that happened was
that when we gave the performance we
had this huge up swell of gratitude
and thanks from the audience
for that particular piece
and people had come in from all over
the place just to hear that piece.
I thought it was the Dallapiccola
that we had also programmed,
but it wasn't that.
[laughter] Although that
was also a nice piece.
But there -- it spoke to me at
a time that there's this element
to your music and it's -- of course
you write lots of different music --
that tends to reach many
different types of people.
And I just thought that I'd
share that as a starting point,
that I had a very positive
experience in that light.
>> Frederic Rzewski:
I'm glad to hear that.
I didn't know that.
Do you know why people
-- ?[laughter]
>> David Plylar: This I do
not know, but they just said
that they were fans of
your music and so just --
it wasn't often performed there.
So --
>> Frederic Rzewski: Probably not.
>> David Plylar: Yeah, so it
was a chance to hear it I think.
Hearing music live is just
also one of those things
that they greatly valued.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well,
it's funny because I had a
similar experience in Athens.
I went to Athens a little more than
a year ago and a lot of people came
to my concert and it turned out most
of them were anarchists [laughter]
and that this piece had been
played a number of times in Athens,
and of course the guy who wrote
the text was himself an anarchist.
So, there was some
connection there and there --
in Athens there are
lots of anarchists.
>> David Plylar: [laughs] Sure.
>> Frederic Rzewski: But
more than that I don't know.
>> David Plylar: I'm not sure
they're a particular [inaudible],
but they certainly enjoyed the music
and the performance
[laughs] to be sure.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well, good.
Yeah.
>> David Plylar: Well, I
thought we'd start with --
I don't know how many people in
this audience were able to come
to the concert last night,
but we had a very -- Oh, good.
I'm glad to see that
some of you were able to.
It was a very unique experience,
and not just for us, the audience,
but also for you, I would
imagine, in that there was a piece
that you had written
when you were 16 or 17.
>> Frederic Rzewski: That's right.
Both actually.
[inaudible]
>> David Plylar: [laughs] Straddled.
And I guess I'm just wondering what
that experience would be like to --
you hadn't ever had
a chance to hear --
you had your experience with it
composing it, clearly invested a lot
of energy, and invested
time, and thought into it.
At least it seemed to --
>> Frederic Rzewski: I was a
student and I didn't know anything
about anything and I
still don't, right?
Truly. [laughter] But I mean,
string quartet, I only knew --
I listened to a lot of
records, but I never played a --
I mean I tried to play the cello
once and I even tried the viola,
but you know there's a
kind of fundamental gap
between keyboard players
and, you know,
it's two completely different
universes and of course the thing
about a piano or a keyboard
instrument is that it's a machine,
a labor saving device
for playing lute music.
[laughter] Well, historically
that is in fact the case
because the lute is a
notoriously difficult instrument,
as I guess you know, and the
keyboard was developed as a way
of making it more available.
I mean and you can see that
in renaissance paintings.
It's the lute -- only
angels play lutes.
[laughter] So -- but everybody
can play a keyboard instrument.
>> Charlton Lee: I can't.
[laughter]
>> Frederic Rzewski:
Well, that's what it is.
And I mean, you know, I
don't know how I got into it,
but anyhow what I really
wanted to say is
that your performance
was spectacular.
>> Charlton Lee: Thank you.
>> Frederic Rzewski:
I mean, it really was.
[ Applause ]
>> Frederic Rzewski: I had
never heard your quartet before,
but it's really fantastic.
>> Charlton Lee: Thank
you very much.
>> Frederic Rzewski:
Aside from the fact
that you obviously worked very
hard on this particular thing,
I can see that you're, you know, a
real quartet and those things aren't
so common these days, but -- So, I'm
going to definitely check you out.
[laughter] But thanks anyway.
I mean it was fantastic because
my piece is, you know, basically,
you know, just a student exercise.
It's not so bad, but it isn't
really that [laughter] exciting.
>> Charlton Lee: [laughing]
Not at all.
>> David Plylar: What I wouldn't say
is your standard student exercise.
I don't remember too many
16-17 year olds who really --
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well I --
>> David Plylar: Mendelssohn
comes to mind.
[laughter]
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well, I was
trying to be avant-garde also
and so forth and, you know, I was
trying to do all kinds of things,
but without really know howing
-- [laughs] how to do them.
And it's just as well it
waited 60 years to be performed
because if it had been informed
then -- been performed then --
then probably some
professor would have said,
"Look dear take this
stuff out [laughter]
because you can't have
these glissandi,
you know, that's ridiculous."
And in fact [laughs]
they are ridiculous.
[laughter] But the extraordinary
thing about your performance was
that you did exactly what's written.
>> Charlton Lee: Well, we thought
about it and we said, "Well,
he was 17 and he probably said,
'I don't care!'" [laughter]
So, we did it.
[laughter]
>> Frederic Rzewski: Yes, you
know, I mean I didn't expect that.
I expected that you were
going to like, you know,
smooth out the [laughs] funny parts.
>> Charlton Lee: I think
because we work so much
with living composers we're
used to starting from the point
of doing exactly what's on the page
and then if they think it doesn't --
if they don't like it they can
change it and then we'll change it.
>> David Plylar: Well, that brings
up an interesting question Charlton,
with the process of preparing
this particular piece you know
that you're going to have
the opportunity to speak
with the composer, but it's at
such a remove that it's really
like everybody's coming to this
piece as if it were a new piece.
Did that affect the way -- or
did you still just go at it just
as if it were a new piece
that's put in front of you?
>> Charlton Lee: We still --
we treat every piece that way.
So, even the two pieces on
these programs by the composers
who are deceased, Crawford
[assumed spelling] and Ontile,
[phonetic spelling] we still
approached them as if they're living
and then -- with like for example
the other day when you brought
out those manuscripts, that was a
treat, and then we can look and,
you know, they have notes written.
It's like, mistake
here, tempo change here,
it's like all this
great information.
Then we of course copy them over.
[laughter]
>> David Plylar: And actually I
think you did some adaptations based
on little minor notes.
>> Charlton Lee: Yeah, we did.
Yeah, there was some
-- in the Ontile --
let's see, when we recorded
the Ontile we had --
there was one notation where he
crossed out one section and --
but this time around we felt like,
actually it makes sense with it.
Well, you can tell us tonight
if it works or not, but --
[laughter] So, we kept
the whole thing this time.
Yeah, it's all the way -- it's all
what he wrote the first time around.
>> Frederic Rzewski: The
Crawford is extraordinary.
I didn't know this piece.
>> Charlton Lee: It's incredible.
>> Frederic Rzewski:
Especially the second movement.
>> Charlton Lee: Yeah.
[laughs] That's --
>> Frederic Rzewski:
No, that really is --
I mean that was an eye --
an ear -- opener for me.
>> Charlton Lee: Yeah.
No, she -- we were talking
as we were working in depth
on this piece we were saying that
because she knew this young fellow
at the time named -- uh oh,
now I'm blanking on a very --
>> Frederic Rzewski:
You mean knew him in --
>> Charlton Lee: Mister
Elliot Carter.
So, he was her kind of a -- you know
he was a younger composer who's kind
of hanging out with
them a little bit.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Them who?
>> Charlton Lee: The
Seegers and other people.
>> Frederic Rzewski: both of them?
>> Charlton Lee: I think so, yes.
>> Frederic Rzewski: This
was before she was married.
>> Charlton Lee: I'm
not sure exactly when --
>> Frederic Rzewski: It
says so in the program.
>> Charlton Lee: Okay, there you go.
And -- oh no, this piece for sure.
>> Frederic Rzewski: This piece.
This was written a year
before she was married.
>> Charlton Lee: That's right.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Which is a --
you know normally it's
not so significant,
but I mean the only thing I
really know about this woman is
that she basically
stopped composing.
>> Charlton Lee: It's a pity.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well,
I'm not sure what that's all
about, but it's not unusual.
Of course the same thing
was true of Moller's wife.
>> Charlton Lee: Right.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Same thing.
>> Charlton Lee: That's right.
>> Frederic Rzewski: And,
you know I mean it's a --
I presume probably very
common in, you know --
>> Charlton Lee: Right.
>> David Plylar: It's
definitely a complicated issue
that has been written
about quite a bit recently.
Judith Tick definitely approaches
it in her biography and some essays
about it, but yes,
but Carter wasn't --
I believe those first string quartet
was actually influenced by --
>> Charlton Lee: I think a lot
of his ideas [laughs] were
influenced by this piece.
>> Frederic Rzewski: By this piece.
>> Charlton Lee: Yeah, exactly.
A lot of the polyrhythms
and the voicing --
voices crossing and all this stuff.
>> Frederic Rzewski: But he didn't
start doing that kind of thing --
>> Charlton Lee: Until
about 15 years later.
[laughs]
>> Frederic Rzewski:
Yeah, well more than that.
>> Charlton Lee: Yeah, or more.
Right.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Because up
until 1950 or so he was writing sort
of your standard neoclassic
Americana kind of thing.
>> Charlton Lee: Yeah.
>> David Plylar: Well,
was this when you --
going back to when you
wrote the string quartet,
was that the first writing
for strings that you had done,
or had you done some
practice pieces before
that for other versions
of the ensemble?
>> Frederic Rzewski: Wait.
>> David Plylar: Or for you to say.
[laughter] When you first
wrote that string quartet was
that your first attempt at writing
for strings or was that -- ?
>> Frederic Rzewski: Oh no.
>> David Plylar: No.
>> Frederic Rzewski:
[laughs] No, no, no.
>> David Plylar: It
didn't sound like that.
>> Frederic Rzewski: There are some
other unperformed -- [laughter]
>> Charlton Lee: We can
make a business out of this.
[laughter]
>> Frederic Rzewski: In fact, I
mean, you know, I stopped writing
for strings because no string
players were interested
and that's still true today.
Nobody is interested in
-- nobody is interested.
I mean look, you probably wouldn't
have done this unless you had been
hired to do it.
[laughter] Let's face it.
I mean string players are just not
interested as a rule in new music.
I mean your group may be
exceptional, but the rule is,
you know -- even at
conservatories I know well
that many teachers tell the
students, "Don't play new music
because it will ruin
your technique."
>> Charlton Lee: Actually for
our case it would have been
if we were disinterested
in the piece
without being hired it
would be because it was old.
[laughter] If you had a new
quartet we'd be all over it.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well, I do.
>> Charlton Lee: Oh, you do.
[laughter] Ooh.
Let's talk.
>> David Plylar: This has all
been an elaborate set up for you.
>> Frederic Rzewski: [laughs] Yes.
Well, yes it's true.
I mean, you know, but -- look
you have to admit that I'm right.
[laughs]
>> Charlton Lee: No, you're right.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Some string
quartets maybe will play let's say
Philip Glass or something
like that, okay?
Why? Because they know
there will be an audience
and this is a perfectly good reason.
But I suppose one good reason
for not playing new music is
because there's really not
very much that's any good.
Well, that happens to be also true.
But how many string quartets for
instance, since we were speaking
about Elliot, how many string
quartets play his work?
How many? Can -- just
off the top of your head.
>> Charlton Lee: For
sure the Pacificas.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Yeah,
but how many string quartets
will actually play this stuff?
>> Charlton Lee: I'm not sure.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Not too many.
>> Charlton Lee: Yeah,
probably not too many.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Of
course it's difficult.
>> Charlton Lee: Yes.
>> Frederic Rzewski: But, you know,
any string quartet music
that's any good is --
has, you know Beethoven too.
So, you know it's not -- these two
things don't really sit comfortably
with each other.
I mean, your group
may be an exception.
>> David Plylar: I
would say that they are
because they have a great track
record of really promoting --
especially living composers -- and
doing great work with their music.
Also with some of the music that's a
bit more obscure that we don't hear
as often, like the Antile, [phonetic
spelling] they have a collection
of all of his string quartet music.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Oh really?
You've recorded --
>> Charlton Lee: Right.
>> Frederic Rzewski:
Well, of course he is --
deserves to be much
better known than he is.
And he has and -- undeservedly
-- not very good reputation.
And even I didn't really know the
work very well and I still don't --
until fairly recently, until
I realized that, you know,
this guy actually wrote
interesting music.
It's hard to say why.
Anyway, let's not stare.
This subject is getting
too pessimistic.
[laughter]
>> David Plylar: Well, maybe we can
look at some of your piano music.
So, moving away from
strings, you're also going
to be playing some solo
piano works tonight.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Yes.
>> David Plylar: Maybe
you can share a few things
about these particular pieces,
or the types of piano [inaudible]
>> Frederic Rzewski: Alright,
now we're coming to
the part that I like.
You know, I suggested today that --
what are we going to
do on this talk?
And I said, "Well, an easy
way of dealing with it is
to let the audience talk."
So, maybe somebody has
[laughs] something to say.
>> David Plylar: Sure.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Yes.
>> David Plylar: If you
don't mind we'll take a --
>> -- Frederic Rzewski: Why
don't you take this mic down?
>> David Plylar: If Jay
[assumed spelling] is [inaudible]
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well
here's what -- right here.
>> I'm -- you said that conservatory
teachers tell the string players not
to play the new string quartets
because it will ruin
their technique.
What did you mean by that?
>> Frederic Rzewski: I just know
what I heard and I used to teach
in the Liaz Conservatory
[phonetic spelling] myself.
And actually the Liaz Conservatory
in Belgium has a long history of,
you know, association with violin.
People like, you know,
all the famous, you know,
Izie [phonetic spelling] and
all these people, you know,
they were all connected with that.
So, they have a long history of,
you know, string teachers and so on.
And people told me that, that,
you know the teachers told them --
told the students, you know,
"Stay away from modern music
because it will ruin
your technique."
And it may be true for all I know.
You know maybe, you know, you
guys play Azul Ponticello very
convincingly, but what is it
like when you play Mozart?
>> Charlton Lee: We
don't use a Ponticello.
[laughs]
>> Frederic Rzewski: Exactly.
So, you know, I mean the
Kronos Quartet is well known
for playing new music,
for better or for worse,
but I also heard them play classics
and they don't do it very well,
or at least they didn't when I
heard them, which was some time ago.
And maybe it's true, you know?
Maybe it's true that if you're going
to play the classics
correctly you should stay away
from this other stuff.
[laughter]
>> Charlton Lee: I happen to think
that it would actually
just expand your pallet,
but it is a common trend that a lot
of conservatory teachers have their
students focusing so primarily
on the classics that they don't have
time really to explore beyond that.
And so a lot of them -- we
were just at -- Where was it?
Oh, we were just at Peabody
last week, giving a class,
and I think people were a little
scared by some of the pieces
that we played because they
had never heard anything
like that before.
And some of it was
not even that far out.
So, it's really -- and
that's not unusual.
I think it's quite common now
that a lot of the students,
if they want to explore contemporary
music, they have to go outside
of the school to access it.
>> David Plylar: I think there's --
>> Charlton Lee: Yeah?
>> David Plylar: I think there's
also different populations of --
different teachers
offer different things
to their students at conservatories.
I mean the root of
that is conservative.
>> Frederic Rzewski: No.
[laughter] I beg to differ.
>> David Plylar: Okay.
>> Frederic Rzewski: In fact
maybe somebody in the audience --
I heard already some
-- just heard protest.
Can somebody tell us what
this word actually means?
No hu? Well, I often, you know,
talk to my students about this.
Well, I lived in Italy
for a long time.
So, the word is conservatorio.
Now, what is a conservatorio?
It is an orphanage because in the
middle ages the church received --
you can still see them in certain
places, in Padua for example,
in front of the Cathedral of Saint
Anthony there is a curious rotund
structure, which has a little
door on it and there's a kind
of lazy Susan inside the door.
Now the whole point of that is that
behind the door on the other side --
behind it on the other side there's
a similar door with a nun waiting
and what you do is if you have a
child which you really can't afford
to bring up, instead of throwing
it in the river you take it
to the church, put it in there,
and on the other side the nun
takes the baby and that's it.
You never make eye
contact or anything.
And so many children were saved
or conservati in this way.
So, the place where --
which receives these children
there is a conservatori,
or place where they are saved.
And of course the church brings them
up and teaches them to do things
like decorating the church,
singing in the choir.
So, many of the famous
painters of the renaissance
and musicians were
[laughs] saved in this way.
And only in the eighteenth century
did Caro Bini [phonetic spelling] go
to Paris and start the
first conservatoire,
which then was -- became
a music school.
But that's not what the word means.
>> David Plylar: I wasn't really
trying to say that's what it means,
but it certainly is
one of those things
that one finds in a conservatory.
>> Frederic Rzewski: [sighs] Well
that happens to be an accident
of language [laughter]
that conservatories
tend to be conservative.
But it's [laughs] nothing
really structurally --
>> David Plylar: Good
to point out, yes.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Yeah.
>> David Plylar: Can we go back
to your piano playing in terms
of what -- I just want to know a
bit more about the types of music
that you've been writing
lately for solo piano.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well,
what would you like to know?
[laughter]
>> David Plylar: Anything
you'd like to tell us.
I --
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well,
you can hear a lot of it.
Just go on IMSLP and most of my
music is there, up for grabs.
You can download the scores
and the recordings, free.
[laughter] So, if you're interested,
you know, you can do that.
Yeah.
>> Then how do you make a living?
[laughter]
>> Frederic Rzewski: The question
was; how do I make a living?
Or should I --
>> David Plylar: We've got it down.
>> Frederic Rzewski:
This way and that way.
[laughter] You know I don't
make much of a living,
but I manage to survive and one
of the ways I make a living is
like thanks to this place.
I got a nice commission to write
these pieces that we're going
to hear tonight and tomorrow.
So, I used to make a living
mostly by playing the piano
and occasionally some kind
of something, you know,
coming in from composing, but
now it's more the opposite.
But let's face it, [laughs] I
just told David, I said that,
"There are lots of good
musician jokes, as we know,
mostly about viola players
[laughter] and trombones
and so forth, and very
few jokes about composers
because it just isn't funny."
[laughter] But there is one I like.
It's -- the composition teacher is
trying to discourage the student
so he says, "Well, what do
you want to get into this for?
It's just one frustration
after another
and they never play your music.
You never get any recognition.
You know, nothing ever happens and
of course there's no money in it
and it just goes on year
after year until you're 50."
And the student perks up and
says, "And then what happens?"
[laughter] And the teacher says,
"Well, then you get used to it."
[ Laughter ]
That's -- I won't tell anymore
because they get more depressing.
[laughter] But, you know, I mean
one doesn't do this for a living.
That's the answer.
If you read music for a living
you're doing the wrong thing.
First of all, if you write
music for money it's probably --
it might be, you know -- you might
do a good job doing commercial
music, but if you're
trying to do something
that is not commercial then it won't
be very good if you're doing it
for money, if I make my point clear.
You know it's very simple,
but that's the truth.
So, like, you know, there are
certain things that you cannot do
for money, first of all because it's
not a very good way of making money,
and secondly because if you do it
for money it's not
going to be any good.
That's all.
And I guess there are
many examples of that.
I mean priests for example,
or for that matter doctors.
I met in Stanford -- I was in
Stanford University a few years ago
and there was a Chinese
student -- pianist --
you know, there are no
music majors in Stanford.
You can major in different
things, but not music.
So -- but many students
study music nonetheless.
So, there was -- I was doing a
piano master class or something
and there was somebody -- a Chinese
woman -- who played quite well.
And so I talked to her afterwards
because I was interested,
you know -- this was in
the nineties so it wasn't
so -- it was a while ago.
Before it was clear
whether China was --
you know, which way China was going
and it was still very much a
communist country, if you like.
And so I asked her, "Well,
what are you really studying?"
She said, "I'm studying medicine."
So, I thought, "Well,
this is interesting."
And, you know -- so I
asked her, "Are you --
you want to become a doctor
because you want to help people
or because you want to get rich?"
And she went, [growls] "Get rich!"
[laughter] So, you know, okay.
This is certainly --
that's possible.
But it's not really a good idea.
I mean there are certain --
there's a fundamental contradiction
there somewhere, it seems to me.
And it certainly is true
in the case of composition.
You just don't do it for money.
So, you make a living
one way or another.
Most people in this
country do it by teaching.
Well, I would have done that
too, gladly, if I had been able
to get a job, but I wasn't.
So, I went to Europe and
did it some other way.
>> David Plylar: Well, you also
had going for you the ability
to perform your own
music, which was,
I think, a helpful exponent of --
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well, yes.
It's good if you can -- if you're
a performing musician it's good
to bring these two things
together as much as possible.
I mean it's good to
get paid when you play,
and that's actually becoming
more and more difficult
as you -- I'm sure you will agree.
>> Charlton Lee: Yes.
>> Frederic Rzewski: There's less
and less money around for culture.
>> Charlton Lee: That's right.
>> Frederic Rzewski:
But that's a long story.
>> Charlton Lee: That's
a very big story.
>> Frederic Rzewski: We
could talk about that
for the rest of the night.
[laughs]
>> Charlton Lee: All night.
>> David Plylar: Well, one
other thing that we're going
to be hearing tonight that I would
love to hear you say a few words
about if you like,
would be the new piece,
the new commission work
for violin and piano.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well, I did
write about it in the program notes
and there's not really
much more to say about it.
>> David Plylar: Well, how much have
you composed for that medium before?
>> Frederic Rzewski:
For violin and piano?
>> David Plylar: Yeah.
>> Frederic Rzewski:
Well, around the time
of this piece you played last night
I also wrote a sonata for violin
and piano and I think
maybe it got lost.
>> Charlton Lee: Oh.
>> Frederic Rzewski: At least
I don't know where it is.
It's kind of in -- I remember
it's kind of in the style
of Bartok or something like that.
So -- and I tried writing for
violin and piano in the meantime,
occasionally a few fiddle players
expressed some interest in it,
but I didn't get very far.
And as I say, I think it was
mainly because, you know,
string players are
basically just not interested.
And, in fact, it is kind of an
antiquated, or archaic, form.
I mean, not string quartet
maybe, but say violin and piano,
or if you think about it
there isn't really that much.
And for that matter, you know,
beside from the Shostakovich Sonata,
what is there for viola
and piano for example.
[laughter] I mean really?
Do you ever -- ?
You must know.
>> Charlton Lee: Actually
I'm focusing so much
on string quartets [laughs] I'm
not really paying attention.
But there's actually
a lot being written.
>> Frederic Rzewski: There
may be a lot written [laughs]
but it doesn't get played and
that's probably a good thing.
[laughter] Is there
any significant -- ?
>> Charlton Lee: I'm so biased just
towards the string quartet it really
isn't fair.
[laughs]
>> Frederic Rzewski: That's fine,
but what I'm saying is that yeah,
I don't think it's -- you know
there may be string quartets,
although there aren't
that many of those either.
That, you know --
>> David Plylar: There's a lot.
Actually you should see the
piles of submissions we have.
>> Frederic Rzewski: That may
well be that there is a lot.
Somebody said something.
--
>> David Plylar: They
were just laughing.
>> Frederic Rzewski:
Oh, just laughing.
Okay.
>> David Plylar: Well, I think
that in any case there's --
whether a medium is played out or
not there's always something to say
in it I think and it seems like --
what's an interesting thing is
that you've done this for us,
and we'll get to hear this tonight.
And kind of as a counterpart we
have the collaborative effort
with the Philips Collection and
you'll be playing another violin
and piano piece tomorrow there.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well,
this is a great idea.
I mean, it's my own
point of view, but --
>> David Plylar: Yeah,
we think so too.
[laughs]
>> Frederic Rzewski: But I think --
you know I think composers would --
most composers would agree
because there isn't a whole lot
of demand for violin and piano.
It just seems like
it's an archaic forum
and therefore there isn't that much.
So, I mean I don't know.
We'll see what it's like.
I have a pretty good idea of
what it's going to sound like
and I think it's not so bad.
But of course I'm the last
person [laughs] to judge.
We'll see.
But I -- but it's a good idea,
you know, to get people to do --
get them back into this form
again because it seems to be --
I don't know I can't get --
I mean you probably know
more than I do about this.
I mean --
>> David Plylar: Well,
the library has a --
this is funded through the McKim
Fund in the Library of Congress,
which as many of you concert
goers who have been to lots
of our concerts, it's a fund
that we've had in place for many,
many years, I think since the
late sixties or early seventies,
and it's commissioned -- I'm trying
to think of the number offhand --
but a number of very large
-- of pieces of, you know,
different styles, different
composers, all those types
of things, but including things
like the Carter duo and other things
like that and some works
by Babbitt and it's a --
it has a wide variety
of opportunities given
for that particular ensemble,
but funding requires it
to be violin and piano.
So, that's one reason why we
stick with that when we do that.
But it certainly has, I
think, enlarged the body
of music available for that.
>> Frederic Rzewski: I think I asked
you, when this first arose, I said,
"Well, does it really
have to be violin?
For instance, couldn't it be viola?"
[laughter] Well, my
daughter plays viola
and of course I was
thinking about that.
And David said, "Nope it
has to be violin and piano."
[laughter]
>> David Plylar: So,
we just need a new fund
that covers viola and piano.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well, my
daughter has this particular point
of view, she thinks that the
real instrument is the viola,
after all violino is just
a little viola, that's all.
[laughter] and the real instrument
is the viola and she thinks what --
you should just have a five stringed
viola, a viola with an E string
and then get rid of the violin.
[laughter]
>> David Plylar: How do you
feel about that Charles?
[laughter]
>> That's how electronic
violins are made these days.
[laughter]
>> Frederic Rzewski:
Yes, I know they --
>> Electronic ones are made with
five -- exactly that, five strings.
>> Frederic Rzewski: I know it does.
>> Charlton Lee: I've even
seen some six stringed ones.
[laughter]
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well,
her point was that, you know,
the thing about the violin --
I think the dramatic part
of the violin is the G
string, the low string.
And she says the G string is
really much better on the viola.
And, you know, actually it's
hard to argue with that.
It's just --
>> Charlton Lee: Then
you have the C string.
[laughter]
>> Frederic Rzewski:
And then you have on top
of that you have that
fantastic C string.
By the way, I did notice your --
you have a particular way of playing
that -- you know the
viola doesn't often stick
out in a string quartet, and you do.
[laughter] Was it because
of the instrument or --
>> Charlton Lee: Are any
of my colleagues here?
[laughter]
>> Frederic Rzewski: No, my
question is -- I mean it --
was the instrument unusually
strong or is it just your -- ?
>> Charlton Lee: No, they
have the big instruments.
The -- I mean, last night Ben
[assumed spelling] was playing the
Chrysler Coronary [assumed spelling]
and Rick [assumed spelling]
was playing the Besk Strata
[phonetic spelling].
They should -- no,
it's probably just me.
I like to play loud.
>> David Plylar: Just a power house.
So, yeah.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Yes.
Well, yeah, I mean I
was impressed by that.
>> Charlton Lee: I mean I -- there's
a wonderful quote from Michael Tree,
[assumed spelling] the former
violist of the Guarneri Quartet,
and he said that the violas
should always play louder
than his colleagues think he should.
[laughter]
>> Frederic Rzewski: Yeah, well
of course we're starting to get
into the area of viola jokes.
[laughter]
>> David Plylar: Well, why don't
we take some more questions.
There's a microphone
that will come to you.
>> Hi, thanks.
You said earlier that
-- or suggested that --
much new music wasn't very good,
but are there any contemporary
composers you particularly
like or respect?
>> Frederic Rzewski: Oh,
yeah quite a few of them.
Yeah. Sure.
I mean, actually there are a lot of
them and the interesting thing is
that -- well it goes up and down,
but there for a while there
it looked as though, you know,
composition might be on the way out.
After all there's no reason why
it should stick around forever
and we can see the art
of painting, for example,
seems to be disappearing,
if not already gone.
The art of painting with
oil colors, which has been
around for say 600 years
or something like that,
since Ja Do [phonetic
spelling], say.
It's, you know, arguably finished
because now we have
something called visual arts.
Well, I've never seen a visual art.
I don't know what it is.
I know what painting is.
I know what sculpture
is, but visual arts
to me is a euphemism
synonymous with nothing.
And the same thing may
be happening with music.
It's clear to everybody I think
that the level of creative --
the creative level of music
has been going down steadily
for the last 100 years, if not more.
And I'm afraid since
Stockhausen was a good composer,
but he wasn't as good
as Richard Strauss,
who in turn was not
quite as good as Brahms.
So, there is clearly
a steady decline
in quality throughout the
twentieth century, which is --
I mean you may argue with it.
You may say, "Well,
actually, you know,
Schoenberg was the greatest
composer who ever lived,
but it won't convince most people.
Of course he was a good composer,
but again so on and so forth --
but whereas -- interestingly the
level of performance has gone
in the opposite direction.
The young performers of today
are better than Horowitz
and you can hear that on -- one of
the advantages of the internet is
that you can just push a button
and compare; [laughs] five seconds.
And it's quite extraordinary
that this is true.
So, it's not at all simple.
It's a complex process and
of course that can be due
to many different factors.
One of them, for example, is the
radio and technology in general
and the media and the monopolization
of the music industry
and etcetera, etcetera.
I mean, basically capitalism
is not good for culture.
Capitalism does not lead to
better art, on the contrary,
it's destructive in many, many
ways including the [laughs] are
of art and culture.
It -- capitalism is --
it's time to get rid of it.
[laughs] We need something else.
I mean, this was not
always true of course.
There -- even in the
nineteenth century much art
and culture owes its existence to
the fact that there were rich people
around who could spend money on it.
But today it is no longer true.
It -- well, okay, this is again
a completely different thing.
[laughs] The point is though
that yes, there are --
yeah, and it's a complex
process and it --
I think history goes in
both directions at once.
It goes forward and it also
goes backward at the same time.
So, for a while it looked as though
there were not very interesting
composers around, and of course
that varies from country to country.
Unfortunately in this
country it's especially true.
A lot of young composers
want to be pop stars.
It's unfortunate, but it's true.
And of course most of them
won't become pop stars,
but some of them do, and some
of them even get commissions
from the Metropolitan
Opera or wherever
and of course you could say,
"Well, this has always been true."
Maybe, but -- So, it's hard --
I can't point to really
any really significant,
interesting young composers
in this country.
I can point to a few in
some European countries.
Now of course I don't know
everything and I don't --
and most of the time I don't live
here so I -- there probably --
and maybe there are
some young people
around who are very interesting
and who I just don't know.
And I would hope that
would be the case.
Probably if Ursula Oppens were
here she would probably be already
protesting, loudly, and saying,
you know, there's this one,
and this one, and this one, and
this one, and of course I know
from long friendship that it's
better not to argue with Ursula.
[laughter] And [laughs] I would be
very happy if that were the case,
but there are some -- a few
interesting younger composers
around in certain places.
So, I wouldn't be surprised if
there's a new kind of generation
that appears that -- One thing that
I think was not good was serialism.
I think serialism did not help
to advance the art of music.
It had a definitely a depressing
quality on the level of music.
A lot of music was produced that
has this academic quality about it,
which did not guarantee its
future; on the contrary.
But even worse, I would say,
was what is known as minimalism.
It's even worse.
And -- but fortunately now you
have some younger composers
who not only don't give a
damn about serial music,
which is already being forgotten,
but even they don't give a damn
about minimalism either
and this kind of green mold
or fungus is growing
on this kind of music,
which before the people
are even dead.
[laughter] At least,
you know, Stockhausen
and Boulez are now gone, but --
[ Laughter ]
But to see this happening already,
you know, this mold growing
on people who are still there,
it's kind of frightening.
>> Charlton Lee: Well, it's kind of
curious that tonight the other piece
that we're playing tonight is
by Ben Johnston and so that --
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well,
he was a very good composer.
>> Charlton Lee: And still is.
>> Frederic Rzewski: And still is!
>> Charlton Lee: He's still alive.
[laughter] He is 90, to be fair.
But he would -- in many ways --
would probably be the antithesis
of a serialist composer because his
whole paradigm was just intonation.
So, he wanted pure ratios
between the pitches.
And so everything was blending in
a beautiful wave, not strange wave.
But so the whole idea about
serialism and, you know,
each half step being a
square root of two --
oh no, twelfth root of
two, or some crazy --
you know, it's like was
completely against his ideas.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well, you
know, the reality is that these --
what you're talking
about is just theory.
That's mathematics.
>> Charlton Lee: Yes.
>> Frederic Rzewski: I mean,
you look at a real piano
after the piano tuner is done with
it, it has absolutely nothing to do
with the twelfth root
[laughing] of two.
It's whatever the piano
tuner thinks sounded good.
>> Charlton Lee: He has
to make magic with it.
>> Frederic Rzewski: And in fact all
pianos are completely out of tune.
>> Charlton Lee: Right.
>> Frederic Rzewski: And if they
weren't they wouldn't sound good.
[laughter]
>> Charlton Lee: Actually I've
heard some that have been --
but then you can only play
specific pieces on them.
>> Frederic Rzewski: No.
The piano I'm going to play on
tonight is a good instrument.
I don't know if anybody
tuned it [laughter] recently.
They probably did, right?
>> Charlton Lee: They were
tuning just as I came in.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well,
I worked on it this morning.
It sounded very good
even before it was tuned.
[laughter] It's probably going
to sound even better now.
But you know piano tuners have
this thing that they talk about,
which I have never understood,
it's called harmonisity.
You know what it is?
It's something about how the spaces
between the intervals gets bigger
as you go from the middle of the
instrument to the outer extremes.
But I have never understood
[laughs] what that actually means.
I think it just means that piano
tuners have found this particular
way of making the instrument
sound good and it probably varies
from instrument to instrument.
So, this twelfth root of
two business is, you know,
it's like E equals MC squared.
You know, maybe it's
true [laughs] but --
>> Charlton Lee: I think it's
-- for us as string players,
of course we're particularly
sensitive to those,
and so to us the piano
basically sounds
out of tune, I'm sorry to say.
>> Frederic Rzewski:
Well, it is out of tune.
>> Charlton Lee: Exactly,
but we hear it.
[laughs] So -- and I think --
So, what we are able to do,
and if you're tuning --
because our tendency is
to tune more pure,
as much as we can.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Pure?
Oh, don't give me that.
[laughter]
>> Charlton Lee: Tuning more
with smaller ratios,
let's put it that way.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Ratios?
>> Charlton Lee: Ratios.
Like --
>> David Plylar: So,
like smaller numbers?
[inaudible]
>> Charlton Lee: Right.
So, a fifth being a
three to two match.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Okay,
I'll take your word for it.
I've never understood these things.
So, I don't know, maybe.
Okay, but any rate, Ben Johnston,
whether he believes this stuff
or not, it doesn't really matter.
The fact was that he wrote --
has written some good music.
>> Charlton Lee: Exactly.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Yeah.
>> Charlton Lee: The
music is really fun.
>> Frederic Rzewski: How
he did it, who cares.
>> David Plylar: I
think we have time
for just about one more question.
>> Okay. Well, I hope,
no [inaudible].
>> Frederic Rzewski: Let's say two.
>> David Plylar: Okay,
two more questions.
>> Okay, is this good?
>> Frederic Rzewski: Why
do we have to stop anyway?
>> Anyway -- [laughter]
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well,
it's only 20 after seven.
When is the concert?
>> David Plylar: Eight,
but we have to open
up the house at seven thirty.
>> Frederic Rzewski:
Alright, well -- [laughter]
>> Okay, so this is a simple one.
You mentioned that if music is
composed for money it won't be good,
but when I read the writings
of composers of the past,
like Dvorak comes to mind, he
was very much writing for money.
He would write about how much he
was going to get for what piece
and how well he was able to deliver
it on time and it was great music.
So -- and other people -- I'm
sure you can think of others.
Has something changed?
And if so, why?
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well, I
don't know that much about Bartok,
but some composers aren't --
>> Charlton Lee: Dvorak.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Dvorak.
Oh, Dvorak -- you were
talking -- not Bartok.
Oh, yeah. Well, I don't know
that much about him either.
[ Laughter ]
So, I don't know.
But some composers
are good businessmen
and there's nothing wrong with that.
I mean, Philip Glass is both a
good composer, I think, you know --
although he's certainly not --
everything he wrote is that good,
but he has done some good stuff and
he's also a very good businessman.
And there's nothing wrong with that.
In fact I once read an
interview with him --
or I actually saw it on YouTube
or on the internet or something --
and somebody asked him something
about like, "Well, you know,
a lot of your colleagues are
critical of you because you're
so successful commercially."
And he said, "Well, actually I
don't see anything wrong with it.
What's -- [laughs] I'm
not hurting anybody."
And he went on to explain.
He said, "You know when I was 15 I
worked in my father's record store
and what I -- we sold
records to people --
people would come into the store
wanting music and gave us money
and I don't see anything
[laughs] wrong with it at all."
You know he just happened
to, you know,
learned how to put the
two things together,
which of course most
composers don't know.
And he does it well.
So, it's true.
I mean there's nothing
wrong with it.
In fact probably it
would be a good thing
if people learned how
to sell your music.
You know, something I've never
really learned, but there --
I guess you can't really teach it.
It has to be learned by experience.
I just know -- all I'm saying is
that I don't think that
should be the goal.
I mean you -- it's good if somebody
pays you, of course it's good,
but if you're doing
something for that purpose --
[sighs] Well, it's
theoretically possible.
I mean, Bach wrote his B Minor
Mass certainly for money.
After all, he was Protestant.
[laughter] But this was a
-- he wrote a Catholic mass.
Now the only explanation for that
is that somebody paid him very well
because he wouldn't normally
do that [laughs] would he?
[laughter] The fact was
that he was able to do it
and people were willing
to pay him for it.
So, I don't know what
the details were,
but there's nothing wrong with it.
>> Charlton Lee: I mean I would
certainly agree that it's a bad idea
to go into music to make money.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Exactly.
Precisely.
>> Charlton Lee: I mean, if you
do wind up making money, great!
But if you go into
music for the purpose
of making money that's a dumb idea.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Yes, I think
that's all I was trying to say.
Yeah, exactly.
He's got -- he hit
the nail on the head.
Does that answer the question?
>> David Plylar: Well,
let's take one more.
>> Frederic Rzewski:
Yeah, I think you had a --
>> Excuse me.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> There's a story about when
he was a taxi driver and --
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well, I
happen to know something about that
because I've known Philip since
the late 60s and he was working
as a plumber down in
SoHo a lot of --
He had a lot of artist friends
who were moving into SoHo
and he would come in
and put in the toilets.
And then he was driving
taxis for a while.
I was living up on Riverside Drive
at a hundred and fifty fifth street
and when he was in the
neighborhood he would come by
and we would have a drink together.
So, I know that.
I mean I've known him
for a long time.
>> Well, the story I heard
was somebody was in his taxi
and they said, "You know you have
the same name as a famous composer."
[ Laughter ]
But that's not my question.
My question is that you
have spoken at times
about a social consciousness or
philosophy that informs your music
and maybe the 32 variations
on "The People United Will Never
Be Defeated" is an example of that,
but I just wondered
where you're at with --
>> Frederic Rzewski: Speaking
too close to the microphone.
So, you're -- and you're not
speaking loud enough so --
[ Inaudible Answer ]
What? [inaudible answer]
>> My question was about having
a social message in your music.
>> Frederic Rzewski:
What is the question?
[laughter]
>> Whether that's an
important thing to you now.
I mean I think that --
>> Frederic Rzewski: To
have a social message?
>> Yeah.
>> Frederic Rzewski: Well, if
you have one it's important
to speak it out, but you
don't have to have one.
It's not necessary to make music
-- to have a social message.
You can write music about
love, death, a lot of things,
but if you have a social message
and you can use music as a way
of expressing it, it's -- well
it's like what Jesus Christ says,
you know; if you have the
light you should not hide it
under a bushel, whatever
a bushel is.
[laughter] It's the same
thing in art or music.
I mean you -- Oscar Wilde
says, "Expression is all."
So, many people have -- and Pablo
Neruda in his autobiography talks
about how he meets a worker
who recognizes him and says
that he too would like to be a
poet and Neruda tells him, "Well,
you are a poet, everybody is a
poet because everybody dreams.
The only difference between
a poet and other people is
that poets write their dreams down."
So, that's all it is really.
So, yeah if you have
something to say about society
and you can use music to say
it, why this is a good thing,
but of course not everybody
does that
and there's no reason
why they should.
Some people do.
Verdi wrote Nabucco, one of his
early operas and there's a chorus
in it of the Jews who are
lamenting, who are crying about how
on the shores of Babylon --
they're on the shores of Babylon
and so forth, and thinking
about their homeland
and that became the Risorgimento.
It's -- began the Italian
Revolutionary Movement.
And so you know it happens.
Pierre De Geyter was asked
by the International --
Socialist International to write a
worker's hymn for the International
and he brought in a kind of folk
song like melody and they said,
[derisive noise] "This
is too low class.
You should write something that's
similar to La Marseillaise."
[laughter] So, he went
back to the drawing board
and he wrote the International,
which had a notable career.
It's now sort of forgotten, but --
and he never received
a penny from it.
A German businessman realized
that sometime in the 60s,
realized that this song had
never been copywrited [laughter]
and there was still a feel
years left in international law.
So, he went and copywrited it
and for the next few years he,
every time the song was played
in a Romanian movie
theater, he got money.
[laughter] Why not?
Well, look I mean Warner
Communications has just recently --
a federal judge just a
month ago or so decided
that Warner Communications had
no right to collect royalties
on Happy Birthday, which
was written by a housewife
in Illinois around 1880 something.
There's absolutely [laughs] no
reason why [laughs] anybody should
get any money for it,
but they were doing it.
Anyway we'll -- [laughter]
>> David Plylar: Well,
just because of the time --
we do have a concert that shortly
and we have to change over the room
as well, but please join me
in thanking Frederic
Rzewski and Charlton Lee.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.